you
planet Earth population roughly 7.5
billion every single member of the human
race has been born on this tiny blue
planet imagine one day everything is
going as usual and then a giant asteroid
happens to collide with earth and just
like that no more humans the most
advanced species ever recorded snuffed
out in an instant that sounds rather
grim doesn't it extinction events like
these are just one of several reasons
that humanity has a vested interest in
becoming an interplanetary species and
one likely candidate for earth 2.0 is
our neighbor Mars unfortunately for us
Mars isn't exactly a tropical resort its
average temperature is around negative
55 degrees Celsius about the same as the
middle of Antarctica in winter then
comes the issue of atmospheric
composition what little atmosphere Mars
has is predominantly made up of carbon
dioxide which would prove fatal for
humans
then there's the lack of a magnetic
field which has left the red planet
defenseless against the solar winds that
have stripped away its atmosphere over
time so it's clearly quite a project but
what would it really take to make Mars
habitable could we possibly terraform it
into a second earth before we get into
the how let's take a look at the why why
would we want to bother with
terraforming Mars there are several
other likely candidates for terraforming
such as Venus Europa and Titan but since
Mars is our closest neighbor it's
currently the most feasible extinction
events aside there are a handful of
reasons creating a backup home planet
might be useful
remember that population count at the
beginning of the video well it's growing
very quickly and many people fear that
there will come a point when the earth
simply can't sustain such huge numbers
it's hard to say what that number might
be or if it even exists at all but the
range of estimates for Earth's carrying
capacity are anywhere from 4 to 16
billion so we could have a long way to
go or we could be living on borrowed
time whatever the case may be having a
planet that could support life could
ease the strain on earth's resources at
least for a little while another benefit
of the massive project would be the
wealth of scientific knowledge that
would inevitably stem from the
challenges we face on Mars
things like artificial gravity and
large-scale eco domes are two likely
candidates since both would probably be
needed for long-term success in
colonization other potential
advancements could include more
efficient transportation to and from
Mars new farming techniques and medical
treatments born from the prolonged
effect of living on Mars now on to the
how
there are four main issues that need to
be addressed in order to make Mars
habitable first raising the temperature
the current average of negative 55
degrees Celsius is too cold for
prolonged exposure second increasing the
atmospheric pressure its current
pressure is too low to sustain liquid
water and without water
Mars can never be truly suitable for
human life next changing the composition
of the atmosphere to allow humans to
breathe safely this would require
supplementing or replacing much of the
co2 in the atmosphere with oxygen to
make it less toxic for humans and
finally protecting the surface of the
planet from radiation since Mars has no
magnetic field to speak of it's
constantly bombarded by charged
particles from the Sun which would be
harmful to would-be colonists and strip
away the planet's atmosphere
fortunately the solutions to most of
these problems go hand-in-hand let's
start by looking at what's arguably the
biggest barrier raising the temperature
it's thought that sometime in its past
Mars actually had large polar oceans at
other bodies of water but in the
countless years since the planet's
atmosphere has been stripped away
leaving only polar icecaps
and large amounts of ice below the
planet's surface the main strategy for
raising Mars as temperature is to
release huge quantities of greenhouse
gases which will gradually warm the
surface melt the co2 rich ice which in
return releases more greenhouse gases
warming the planet more and so on until
the polar ice caps have melted and
become oceans there have been several
suggestions of how best to kick-start
this greenhouse domino effect and some
of them seem downright laughable at
first glance one early idea was to set
up factories on Mars which would pump
out large amounts of greenhouse gases
but the logistics of shipping the
materials needed to build such factories
all the way to Mars make it cost
prohibitive the other options would be
much less expensive and a whole lot more
fun because they involve bombarding Mars
with either asteroids or nukes now
blasting Mars with such destructive
force is only an option if plans for
colonization are several decades or
centuries off because we wouldn't
exactly want to set up shop in a
radioactive wasteland but the idea isn't
ridiculous many asteroids contain ice
rich with ammonia which has the
potential to be a potent warming agent
when released on impact with Mars many
scientists believe introducing a large
amount of ammonia into the atmosphere
would be enough to kick-start a runaway
global warming cycle putting Mars on the
fast track for further improvements
using nuclear bombs as the plan to
choose if we don't feel like wrangling
and redirecting asteroids some Mars
hopefuls most
Elon Musk suggests that detonating
thermonuclear warheads over the poles
could provide a large boost in
temperature and help melt polar ice and
you know maybe getting rid of some of
our weapons of mass destruction wouldn't
be such a bad idea
one final less destructive method of
melting the polar ice caps would be to
position giant mirrors in orbit near
Mars to concentrate rays from the Sun of
course this would take much longer and
not be nearly as fun as nuking another
planet but if environmental preservation
is the objective mirrors are a good
option once we have a more habitable
temperature we'd have to face the task
of producing oxygen for humans to
breathe there are several ways of
achieving this first and most
expensively we could simply ship gas
canisters full of oxygen or pumps that
could produce it such an endeavor faces
the same problems as establishing
factories on Mars it's just too
expensive that's where plants and
bacteria come in scientists are
currently working on a project that
would send special bacteria or algae to
Mars that could use Martian soil as fuel
to produce their own oxygen depending on
how efficient these organisms are they
could either be deployed over the entire
planet's surface and left to their own
devices or we could establish smaller
biospheres in which colonists could work
on various projects including farming
and producing oxygen for use outside the
domes after many years of oxygen
production possibly helped along in the
future by more advanced production
methods the biospheres would become
unnecessary and the air on Mars would be
breathable finally there's the challenge
of Mars's lack of a magnetosphere in
order to deal with the destructive solar
wind
we'd have to create some kind of
artificial magnetic field while this
goal will be very difficult to achieve
it also holds the possibility of being
the single most effective way to
replenish the planet's atmosphere and
kickstart the natural processes required
to become habitable in late February of
2017 NASA scientist Jim green suggested
that deploying a magnetic dipole field
between Mars and the Sun could allow the
planet to recover from countless years
of solar bombardment this field would
require a super powerful magnet with a
strength measured at one to two Tesla to
be positioned in l1 orbit greens
research paper proposes that if such a
magnetic field could be deployed within
years mars could achieve half the
atmospheric pressure of earth with a
proper atmosphere in place frozen co2 at
the poles would begin to sublimate
warming the climate ice caps would begin
to melt and form oceans and we could
potentially see a habitable Mars in the
reasonably near future of course even if
we started terraforming Mars
day we wouldn't see the results tomorrow
or in a year or even ten years but if we
want to secure humanity's future as an
interplanetary species and reduce the
odds of total extinction events we've
got a lot of work to do as always I've
provided links for further reading in
the description make sure to subscribe
if you haven't already and follow second
thought on your favorite social media or
just drop in and hang out on the
official discord server you can watch my
previous video by clicking here or watch
them all by clicking here thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video